the soft white underbelly subscription
channel is now two months old and for
those who would like to support what i'm
doing or would like even more of the
content you see on youtube this is a way
to do that
for ten dollars a month you get ad free
uncensored versions of all the videos
you see on youtube plus a lot of
exclusive content
and these videos are watchable on
android and apple mobile devices roku tv
apple tv and amazon fire as well as the
software underbelly.com website which is
how you subscribe to it
the videos on this channel are posted
the night before rather than the morning
of when they're posted on youtube and
there's a one week free trial if you'd
like to check it out
here's a sampling of some of the
exclusive content that's been on this
channel for the last month or so
do you ever feel love as a child [ __ ] no
you know
i just stayed stayed to myself you know
but if she were to die today or tomorrow
or this week i'll be hoeing every day
just so i can [ __ ] survive do
you feel like you're able to love
yourself
i think i i think
i don't know um a hard question
no
i don't think so
i don't i don't i don't know what that
means i really don't
see me or you know anybody's kids seeing
a naked woman walking down the street
crying and screaming and
i didn't feel like i had much to live
for um
my friend came over asked if i wanted to
try heroin
and ultimately that's how i got started
i always called choice or something and
they said don't go down the skid row
don't go down that dome
so i ended up stabbing him in the head
to the left eye
just wherever whatever works man as long
as i get my [ __ ] money
my first time getting the dress was five
i was fine but my first time ever
walking the street in the dress was
amazing to me
paid him to beat me up and uh he raped
me twice
and then he beat the [ __ ] out of me and
he stabbed me with a knife
definitely um reputation and um
you gotta you gotta give people respect
because they'll kill you if you don't
you know
suffered from anedonia from you know
shooting speed for 30 years and
like a lot of my dad's friends ended up
doing you know they just ended up
killing themselves because they couldn't
feel pleasure anymore
but i'm not gonna lie i did have a
wheelchair and like i was hoeing in my
wheelchair because
i loved buddy i did me personally as a
kid you know like all i all i ever
wanted when i was a kid was just to be
loved you know i mean like i just wanted
you know i just wanted a dad or you know
i mean like a family like a unit you
know
there was a lot of abuse
neglect
you know rape
molestation
see when i was 14 i had all the problems
in the world i thought you know plus i
knew everything already
she's going to end up going with
somebody that has a little bit you know
what i mean it has the dope
it's just that's just how it works
i've heard you in school
i was in
sixth grade
you quit after that
yeah
what'd you do after the sixth grade
when went on the road
you went on the road with who
went myself with chucklers
first time i tried crack math heroin
acid all that stuff i was with my mom
so whether you watch on youtube or on
the subscription channel thank you for
subscribing thank you for watching
and i'll see you tomorrow thanks
you